There's something I never told you
it isn't what you think so it's gonna be
Ant-Man
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
just got the new Ant-Man and the wasp Quantumania
trailer we've learned that this Kang the Conqueror
will be the one that they fight in Avengers five
Kang Dynasty and why he needs ant-man's help if
he's so powerful it's because he was trapped in
the quantum realm and he's trying to escape so
I'll explain why he was trapped and how that's
going to affect the rest of Marvel Phase 5 Marvel
phase six because obviously he has very big plans
for the entire Multiverse all of reality we're
going to be getting a bunch of Marvel trailers
really soon too so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos we're also
getting the Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer
pretty soon as well but during the events of
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania Ant-Man has been
living with his family happily since the end of
Avengers end game of all the Avengers all the
heroes we've seen in endgame he seems like his
life has been the happiest of all them like black
panther just died Falcon can't get a bank loan the
eternals just got a Celestial stuck in the
Indian Ocean bad things have been happening
to all of them but Ant-Man got famous not that
famous because they have all the jokes about
people confusing him for Spider-Man man who's a
much more famous character he wrote a bestseller
book he's been hobnobbing with celebrities and
big premieres his life with hope Van Dyne his
daughter Cassie Lang seems like it's been going
great Cassie's supposed to be a chip off the
old block and getting herself into all kinds of
trouble without realizing it she creates a special
distressed Beacon thinking she's going to help
people with potential rescues using the quantum
realm itself Quantum energy and in the trailer we
see her open a gateway to the quantum realm when
she turns it on and all of a sudden Janet Van
Dyne does a 180 from Happy Grandma enjoying her
time back with her family her quiet life flips out
turn it off turn it off now if we have that scene
in the trailer that I included at the beginning of
the video here where she comes clean with hope Van
Dyne because they all get separated when they get
sucked into the quantum Realm by Kang it was Kang
that sucked them in she says there's something
that she never told them about her time being
stuck in the quantum realm remember she was stuck
down there for over 30 years the critical pieces
of information she never told Hank Pym or Ant-Man
was first about the threat of Kang the Conqueror
just in general like there's a super dangerous
master of time I'm living down there let's not
let him out in second she never told them that
she used to be Kang's partner not in crime she
wasn't his partner in crime she just worked
with him before she knew what his true plan was
remember she's supposed to be a genius engineer
too she spent 30 plus years down there trying to
find a way to escape the only way she eventually
made it out was when Hank Pym and Ant-Man opened
a portal down there in some signals and she
was able to randomly pick up on that signal
and she even said it was a one in a million shot
that she detected their signal to begin with but
the idea was that Hank Pym had not been spending
all these years going down to the quantum realm
like he'd only just started doing that recently
otherwise he might have found her and might have
found Kang the Conqueror much sooner the way the
quantum realm exists relative to the rest of the
Multiverse all of reality sort of protects it from
a lot of the larger goings on so for instance the
snap did not affect what happened in the quantum
realm but what had happened is back in the 1980s
Janet Van Dyne got stuck down there during her
accident to stop the missile during her time
down there she finds the quantum City she meets
all these alien cultures that are are living
down there she calls it an entire universe that
lives down at that level but the way it exists
is a little bit different like it's one Quantum
realm for infinite universes it's kind of like a
substrate that connects to the entire Multiverse
which is why it's so important for Kang while
she's down there Janet Van Dyne meets other human
Nathaniel Richards who she doesn't know is Kang
the Conqueror she just thinks that it's Nathaniel
Richards like this other human that got trapped
down there remember he was born a human of Earth
in the distant future his real name is Nathaniel
Richards he's biologically related to Reed
Richards distantly related but still related so
a couple of geniuses working together to try and
Escape until she eventually learns what his real
plan is like oh you're this dangerous person who's
trying to conquer all of reality what had happened
with this version of Kang is that he went through
a version of the Kang Multiverse war and they were
doing a larger version of what Thanos was doing
during his Arc trying to balance the universe by
going around Planet by Planet one at a time the
slow way until eventually he gets The Infinity
Gauntlet and he's able to balance the entire
universe with one snap of his fingers the kang
Multiverse war is basically the same thing with
Kangs going around balancing each Universe each
timeline one at a time the slow way this came the
Conqueror variant wanted to use the quantum realm
as his sort of Infinity Gauntlet solution to speed
everything up like a one ring of power in The
Lord of the Rings one ring to rule them all one
Universe to rule them all so she's been working
with Kang the Conqueror they've been building
this time travel platform from the comics which
is basically what this is like it's a version of
his time travel platform that he uses to control
time while that's happening she eventually learns
the truth about what his plans are and bolts on
him and cripples his ability to escape just as
that's happening she detects Hank pym's signal
and is able to use that to escape before he's able
to track her down but in the time since that Kang
has developed countermeasures for that which is
what happens here when he detects Cassie Lang's
signal and pinpoints them pulling them into
the quantum realm and capturing Cassie Lang to
force Ant-Man to help him the reason why he needs
Ant-Man specifically because he's supposed to be
so powerful why would he need someone like Ant-Man
to help him he is missing a critical piece of his
time travel platform from the comics and basically
that's what this is this giant source of energy
that you see him running towards it seems like
it's some special kind of quantum energy like not
just regular Quantum energy because Hank Pym uses
that in his Pim particles it's very common down
here Kang wouldn't be trapped if that was the only
thing that he needed it almost seems like it's
the wreckage of one of Kang's previous attempts
like it's the wreckage that landed him stuck in
the quantum realm and when that happened there was
some special reaction that went off that's causing
this weird Nexus of energy that he needs now to
power his new time travel device to escape where
you see all these Ant-Man variants running towards
each other some of them dying in the process like
these are all meant to be different variants of
Ant-Man who seem like they're being killed as
they run towards this because in all this later
footage you see the same Red Energy when they're
standing inside what looks like the wreckage of
a ship because a lot of this seems like the same
technology that you see Ant-Man walking around in
that's not broken in the reason why Kang is making
Ant-Man do this by holding Cassie laying hostage
is because he would go through the same thing if
he tried to do it himself so he just wants to
get a patsy to do it for him the whole idea
is that Ant-Man is disposable like there's the
joke in the trailer where he says have I killed
you before like he's killed multiple variants of
Ant-Man before like it's no big deal like oh I've
killed a bunch of Avengers because he's been stuck
down here for so long he's also probably tried to
have other beings in the quantum realm do this
for him unsuccessfully and only Ant-Man has the
skills needed to do whatever it is that he wants
the other big teaser for Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
here is when he says he's an Avenger and Kang
asked if he's killed him before it's because he's
already conquered other timelines before he got
stuck in the quantum realm he's already conquered
other universes so he's already fought and killed
multiple versions of the Avengers teams remember
this isn't supposed to be Kane the Conqueror at
the beginning of his attempt to conquer reality
this is like the middle of his journey after he
decides to work smarter not harder like oh I could
go balance the entire Multiverse one Universe
one timeline at a time or there's a faster way
to do it why don't we just use the quantum Realm
and that's when he gets stuck down there so the
idea is that this is the version of Kang that
they'll face in Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty like he
will escape at the end of the movie and he'll be
able to enact his plan to collapse all of reality
and control it the same way that he who remains
was doing just in a slightly different way with he
who remains there was this broad definition of the
timeline but there were a couple variants within
that timeline there were a couple other universes
so there was a version of the Multiverse but it
was a much smaller subset of the Multiverse where
the different universes didn't contain dangerous
variants of Kang the version of the Multiverse
that they unleash at the end of the Loki series is
like the full true Multiverse infinite universes
with infinite versions of Kang so that's why I
think at the end of this movie it'll have that
special tag that they have at the end of Marvel
movies so and so where we'll turn at the end of
this movie it will say Kang will return and he
will return in Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty and if
it wasn't clear this version of Kang came after
the he who remains version of Kang was killed
and freed when all the other timelines of the
other possibilities of Kang rose up across the
Multiverse so even though he's been trapped in
the quantum realm for many many years when the
events of the movie pick up technically he was
born in the future of the current timeline and
then came back issues that the current timeline is
a rebooted version that came after Sylvie killed
he who remains so technically most of the movies
we've been watching in Marvel phase 4 have been
part of that rebooted version of the timeline
the way they talk about the sacred timeline like
the version that he who remains controlled that
includes all the movies that took place during the
infinity Saga all the way up to Avengers end game
we'll be getting Loki season 2 episodes next year
so we'll talk more about this when those episodes
drop there'll be a lot of Kane back and forth
between the version of Kang that we see on that
series and this version of Kang the Conqueror
now Kang isn't the only villain in the movie
Bill Murray is also billed as one of the main
characters in the film and he's supposed to be
playing a version of krylar who's also one of the
villains he's a super deep cut from the comics and
he's not human in the comics but they might have
changed that for the movie so that Bill Murray
doesn't have to walk around in a bunch of makeup
he also wants to dominate like Kang the conquer
if given a chance and he's supposed to be the
person who's responsible for turning Corey Stahl's
darren cross into the MCU version of MODOK who
looks like this at the end of the first Ant-Man
movie he didn't die he was also sucked into the
quantum realm where Bill Murray's character turned
him into MODOK and it's a bit of the comic book
MODOK Arc the difference in the comics is that aim
turned a regular human into Modoc but obviously
they're doing it for Darren Cross in this movie
we'll get a new trailer for this really soon with
a bunch more footage and clues about what's going
on of course I'll do a video for it if you have
any big questions that I didn't address in this
video like what's going on with Kang just write
them Below in the comments I think we're supposed
to be getting that Guardians of the Galaxy 3
trailer next week or really soon too I think
it'll be a larger version of the trail that we got
at Comic-Con I've already done a much bigger video
for that trailer you can click here to watch that
and click here for my new Deadpool 3 trailer video
and learn how the TVA more Kang Loki connections
are going to be showing up during Deadpool 3.
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!